hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah hey gang today's episode is
brought to you by one of our favorite
sponsors and that's dick
your door dot com baby that's what we're
talking about dick at yourdoor.com has
the perfect gifts for anyone you love
hate or just happen to have their
address send them something
go to dick of your door calm and see if
you use the promo code garbage
you'll save 15 on your order now let's
get
to the show welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley oh baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show where
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find out if they grow up classy or
if they're complete trash
i'm your host holly coming at you on a
beautiful day here
in the east village new york city alive
and well
as we've been [ __ ] saying we ain't
going anywhere we're here for the long
haul baby
my co-host coming at you right next to
me wearing his oldest black t-shirt
but the eyebrows and the hair are
looking pretty sharp these days
sure gang you know the drill the next
time you're reaching for a best pal do
yourself a favor make it a kippy tastes
great he's less filling
and now available in a hard cider
kevin james ryan everybody only till
october 31st so act
now now with pumpkin dude you look like
the catcher from sandlot i can't
that's [ __ ] what are you doing god
damn you are letting it
go i'm leaning into it baby guy gets a
little bit of cash
all of a sudden he [ __ ] checks it and
checks out what the [ __ ] going on here
we're running a tight ship christian
bale from [ __ ]
the big short dude you're dressed like a
fat [ __ ] 13 year old
uh what's up shut up man you should sit
in that computer chair backwards like
you're at the [ __ ] max
um what's up everybody make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube you can
subscribe there as well
and then everybody knows guess
digitalnetwork.com you go there you use
promo code ayg you sign up for the
network you save a couple of bucks
we make a couple of bucks a couple of
fuzz holes so [ __ ] win-win you let me
wet my beak you know what i mean
my lights get to stay on for another
month that's right uh
yeah that's it thanks guys very nice and
gang let me tell you something we could
not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today
uh this young man you've seen him on
bill burr's ringers and of course the
comedy jams
and of course you know him from ephesus
for family dj hall and hank
ladies and gentlemen all the way from
the [ __ ] ghost
do me a favor give me a nice big round
of applause for mr josh adam myers
everybody
yeah yeah just kids here just touched
down baby
flew in from the coast first class by
the way
the [ __ ] christian bail reference
i just watched that on the airplane i
literally i
love that movie great movie great movie
his outfits were
garbage yeah and you're like
lean the [ __ ] in dude you know what it
looks like you're looking newman from
jurassic park we got doctor over here we
got nothing
where's my shaving cream can you oh god
i got this i got this dinosaur
yuck on my face i'm going to spit in
your face midway through i like how he
was
i was eating apple pie at a
dinosaur park yeah buddy thanks so much
for coming
in right from the airport right in the
airport [ __ ] trooper
i almost uh i almost i sound kippy
i almost first thing i did when i got to
the studio was take a [ __ ] and then i
would have been like well then this
episode would have been three minutes
long
yeah yeah because that's garbage you
should just should you just smell up gas
digital studios
yeah you're trash you are trash yeah i
still haven't felt comfortable to take a
doo-doo here
really nah i've done a little pee-pee
we're still the new guys yeah we just
signed i can't be clogging the [ __ ]
toilet next thing bobby hutches the
whole thing i'm getting yelled at
dude you guys are like front page gas
digital you know yeah it's because what
a [ __ ] diarrhea in that [ __ ]
because it's alphabetical because we're
it's are you garbage which
that's like you know when you're like
triple a painting or whatever like so
you come up first in the phone smoking
mirrors i thought it was like this
i was like dude they're taking over dude
no it starts with an a
i thought so too and then my ego got
checked
you know what's funny about taking the
[ __ ] like i'm i'm okay with taking the
[ __ ] anywhere it's just i don't want to
have anybody experience it
and when the clubs were open [ __ ]
sure enough
after a show i'd have to [ __ ] really
go and i try to time it out
and as soon as i came out of the
bathroom there'd be some [ __ ] hot
chicks standing there like
oh my god you were really oh my god
nikki glazer is like is anybody in there
he's holding my hair
oh buddy thank you so much for coming
down it's my pleasure i i when i saw
this podcast and what it was about
i said uh because i am garbage
i'm admitted but i'm reformed that's
what
we'll find out we'll find out don't
start don't start making statements
because we're just going to disprove you
because we we're we're we're [ __ ]
surgeons when it's coming all right
no i'm excited to get to the bottom of
my garbage bag i really am
tell us uh tell us the origin story here
where'd you grow up what was the what
was the scoop
so i was i was born about 20 minutes
right outside of washington dc in
germantown maryland suburb
uh montgomery county maryland it's one
of the richest counties
in the country because that's where all
of like the politicians kids live
well politicians live they live out in
the uh you know
uh like outside of dc more in like
potomac but i was germantown very
uh racially diverse which
which is super lucky because you're
growing up with you know it's not like
anything has ever been a culture shock
sure so i grew up in a very diverse
neighborhood
uh my my parents uh you know
my my dad when i was born
was an accountant for adp and was making
a shitload of money right
but then he left his job
and started when i think he went into
sales okay
and just sucked balls like so
bad dude sucks so bad at sales say
goodbye to the pool
oh dude well no this is what i'm saying
we we got my mama to start
working and my dad uh kind of fell into
this depression and then he got a job as
an organ man
so like spraying like pest control but
to the stars so he's going like they
have this big dj
elliot in the morning so he's doing like
ellie in the morning's house yeah
and steve you're bragging at the other
dirt balls at school my dad kills
roaches at elliot's house he was at
stephen spielberg's cousin's house
two weeks ago look at his t-shirt gun i
got
who needs concert tickets they got water
bugs
so so we like i remember
like growing up uh there was a time
where it was like we had no money
i mean we were like really struggling we
actually
uh lost our house but my dad's best
friend
bought the house from us okay uh and
rented it back to us wow
yeah which is great that's a solid
[ __ ] move but he gets to wet his beak
a little bit yeah
you know what i don't know because the
sale getting it back
uh was my after i graduated high school
so actually
senior year of high school i i got i
remember i came home one day because i
used to come home and my parents would
be like either fighting
yeah my mom's crying and they're just
like because they just they did not love
each other like they were just together
because
they didn't want to because my mom
didn't want to leave my dad because he
would just be homeless
you know my dad was just like he's great
dude he's dead but you know he's he's
he wasn't good with money got that being
said i got the same thing buddy i got
you
oh perfect yeah so we all right so but
then i'm not good with money either
i see i am now yeah i am not dude the
best thing that
the coronavirus uh did to me was just
change my spending habits where now i
think about
every dollar
hit me with the allen iverson crossover
[ __ ] breaking ankles in the studio
[Laughter]
i got excited
we got a hot one workout about two hours
of sleep
so so i so we i came home one day
and my mom and my dad were like we're
crying but tears of joy because my great
uncle died
[Laughter]
[ __ ] but he left me and my
sister and a couple other cousins our
age
40 grand each damn and i had never
had any money before right so like for
me this was like
it was [ __ ] it this was like i was
like i'm a [ __ ] millionaire are you
gonna get this they were
they were excited because they were
gonna pay the mortgage exactly so
the whole deal was me and my sister both
had to give we both decided well we
didn't decide they decided
for us to give to give us give them half
the money so that we each gave them 20
grand okay and that was enough money to
buy the house back
oh sure uh or at least make the downpour
then with the rest of the money i just
[ __ ] yeah yeah blew it dude
how old were you i was 18. they're 20 20
grand at 18.
good night i was buying everybody
[ __ ] we go to tgi fridays everybody
get you want santa fe egg rolls
bring them in santa fe egg rolls ain't
cheap dude you ready for the most i
don't think they're from santa fe either
no you ready for the most garbage [ __ ]
ever so i had never had nice clothes
so i just started buying [ __ ] this is
also like at the height of fleece
oh you remember when fleece was fleece
was big yeah fleece was huge
i'm still wearing it now i mean it's
comfy
it gets cold here it only lasts a couple
of days and the lynch just [ __ ]
embedded
so one day i went to the mall i spent
two thousand dollars on fleeces
on fleeces fleeces 2 000 ralph lauren
timberland ralph lauren put together a
nice pull over back
oh yeah shut out the [ __ ] ralph oh
yeah where did they go wrong
isn't polo kind of shitty now no i don't
think so it's
well they have they they have a couple
off shoot brains well they they went
higher
they what did they there was like they
have like their [ __ ] purple label or
something the high went high the low
went really real
yeah and now there's no middle ground
you know what i mean uh i mean
dude tim dillon's supporting half their
business with his [ __ ] shirts
that's all he wears the thing about the
things the thing about polo is i got i
had a couple of big
i got some big guys in my family and
they don't they'll go up to [ __ ] 30x
so you can buy as big as possible and
still look presentable
they're the only they're the only
because we've had to do weddings where
you think to know yeah we got to do
weddings where everybody had to wear
like the same polo or whatever and
they're like you have to do ralph lauren
because you can get like a [ __ ] 6x
forget about it that's a big
[ __ ]
6x yeah there's a couple of big boys in
the family how many x's does it go to
like what the [ __ ] you're looking at me
for i'm a four x
i'm saying here is a large what do you
got dude if he's a four x what the [ __ ]
is a six x
yeah i got i mean i got guy you don't
wanna know yeah i got dudes in my family
that are like six seven like
four seven x yeah yeah probably yeah
yeah we were trying to get if
we got some t-shirts we were trying to
get them for a couple listeners and i
reached out to uh
the merchandise person they're like now
we tap out at 3x
yeah we had listeners like can you give
us a 6x i'm like dude
i appreciate
just buy two shirts yeah holy [ __ ] see
it's so [ __ ] 20 grand you dropped
[ __ ] two grand you're [ __ ] close
you're the hottest kid in [ __ ]
uh oh i was buying everybody weed i was
buying everybody drugs
did they say that they say that you
could do whatever you wanted or were
they
there was a there was like it had to be
a conversation when you got home from
the mall that day
i they they've said to me post they said
they wish they never would have given me
the money
oh it had the access to a car just to go
buy [ __ ] because i blew it within the
first year yeah i went but
but the cool [ __ ] that i did do was that
i backpacked through europe for six
months
there you go that's worth the [ __ ] 20
yeah so i did that and then i came back
to
uh the dc area and then i started i
dropped out of college
and i started working in a restaurant
and you know uh going to raise what was
the name of the restaurant
well it had a change it changed a couple
times so it started
it was never a good it was yeah it was
mozzarella's
then it was mozzarella's the american
cafe
then it was mozzarella then it was just
the american cafe
it's but it was it was an offshoot of
ruby tuesdays
okay so to give you an idea i'll tell
you ruby tuesday
yes so so uh there was
so then i uh yeah it's crap lots i've
never heard
was it a chain or was it like a
stand-alone piece that they were trying
or was it like the purple label of
[ __ ] of ruby tuesdays
i think it was a purple day but yeah i
think it would be like it was supposed
to be like
mozzarellas it's nice we can do it it
was but it wasn't really italian though
do you know what i mean it was more like
they had like cajun pasta like
that's that's the [ __ ] they did it was
like the cajun shrimp
pasta was but it's alfredo sauce just
with a little bit of cayenne pepper why
does everybody think [ __ ] alfredo is
[ __ ] classy
olive garden man they pushed hard in the
[ __ ] 90s and 2000s put shrimp alfredo
in front of something they [ __ ] line
up around the block
yeah they do it i don't know i'm a fan i
don't know how long it's been steph had
alfredo
i haven't had in a long time but it's a
long time me either
i'm marinating for breakfast yeah yeah
of course
i'm a cream sauce if i could put alfredo
sauce on my cereal in the morning i
[ __ ] would
the cinnamon toast crunch alfredo style
al dente crunch cinnamon toast crunch
alfredo
here at mozzarella american cafe
all right so you're working in a
restaurant so i feel like i've left out
so much about my
my childhood yeah go back buddy yeah
because i wanted to talk about port so
so i i this is the the weird thing about
me though regardless if my family
was you know financially
like middle class dipping into lower
middle class like at one point
like my dad went to college my mom went
to college like my sister's a doctor
okay um okay nice you come from good
stock
yeah but i was like the bad kid yeah
dude i i was just getting in trouble
right from the beginning of like i
remember like in
in in kindergarten i got in trouble
for like trying to hit on one of the the
patrols on the bus
i was like throwing what are you doing
after this
i honestly think i honestly think i was
like a seven-year-old like
like [ __ ] like what do they call it
you know not sexual assault but you know
what's the other one cat caller cat
caller yeah dude i mean what now would
be
like crossing i would have been
cancelled at in first grade
he's he's on the corner smoking a cig
what time you get done hey how you doing
let me clear up a seat for you yeah yeah
yeah you ever been the mozzarellas
do you like police honey you're getting
cold put this on
um but i was but i was just kind of like
like i was already a funny kid um and
everybody like i was friends with
everybody but i would just
i would just get in trouble and then and
then i wouldn't get into fights
nothing like that but as we started
getting into
high school uh because i i so all right
so middle school
was me wanting to be black okay because
it was like public enemy yeah i was
hanging out with all the black kids
and i had like the lines of my eyebrows
i had a couple raiders hats back in the
day with a black turtleneck [ __ ]
rocking it i can go bad for a white kid
some white kids can't most black kids
can pull it off
with a white kid with the lines in the
eyebrow i could not
oh no it wasn't my finest hour sure but
i wasn't i was i wanted to be a part of
this all
black a gang if you want to call it that
called the raider boys so when you said
the raiders hats i was like oh dude
like i wanted to be in that show so bad
but then i got
into high school and that was when i
started drinking in ninth grade i
started drinking my friend greg
we'd steal from my parents liquor
cabinets nice and then and then that was
also that right around the time that i
started hearing like stone temple pilots
and now i
music has always been this big thing in
my life right um like i can
i remember my earliest memory is like
being obsessed with iron maiden and hair
metal and then
i can pinpoint the exact moment i heard
guns and roses appetite for destruction
yeah
changed my life how old are you from me
asking right now 40.
first i'm 44. so i'm right there with
you yeah so it blew my mind dude
dc 101 i'm listening on my clock radio
it was like 10 o'clock at night and they
were like there's a new band out of l.a
called guns and roses we're going to
play their whole album all the way
through
and it was just the next day i stole
money from my parents to go buy it
and that was another thing that i was
doing like i forgot to say i mean
there's a big chunk
i still talking over banks on the
weekend hitting a couple of red trucks
yeah i stole from my my parents they had
this little envelope
just all these 20s and i would take them
out and i go like buy friends pizza
or i buy like tapes for everybody i
remember one time i took out money
the day i got caught i remember i just i
just left indiana jones in the last
crusade
and i was like ryan i just had popcorn
and milk dud
residue on me and then then i got
grounded but i also took from my sister
and then that ended uh because i never
had money
i don't know what i mean i never had
money i was the same i remember i got
i remember my mom would be like oh we're
going to the movies or the mall or
whatever it's probably 16
and she's like oh i don't have any cash
like here take my debit card go get 20
bucks out at the wawa and bring me back
my card and then you can go
well i mean you know this dumb brother
you don't know what's happening and then
dude i literally get a call i took out i
took out 40.
okay i took out 40. you know i'm a
[ __ ] gentleman i just need a little
bit of walking
yeah 40 bucks what's going on here you
know what i mean so
i hit it for 40 dude and by the i'm not
even back home it's like a four-minute
drive to drop her back off the [ __ ]
debit card i'm
i'm not even home and i get a call she
goes you took out forty dollars go [ __ ]
she got online banking god damn [ __ ]
this yes cause
she didn't know she didn't know how to
turn the computer on the older you get
the more you pay attention to your
checking
of course like you're in your 20s you're
like yeah because if you just look and
you're like what the [ __ ] is this 200
expense for i don't know what that is i
was probably [ __ ] up yeah and you're
just like all right whatever your
parents
always he would have to do it like on
like bounce the checkbook before online
before she got online banking
we bounced a checkbook so 20 bucks here
and there she wasn't you know
she didn't know she didn't know what the
[ __ ] was happening i'd take out 20 to
take out 40. what did i get kevin carter
you don't [ __ ] know
30 days ago what would you say what'd
you say to me i said yeah you got i'm
sure how long you've been doing that
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] those guys oh
really oh yeah i was [ __ ] stealing
money from her
getting in trouble when you were the old
switcheroo yeah getting in trouble when
you were kids one thing but when they
start putting pieces together and they
realize you've been doing it for a long
time
yeah and they start digging in you know
how long you've been doing this
then you're like a career criminal yeah
yeah yeah they're really
like it's a one time only thing i swear
to god i got mixed up with the wrong
crowd
empty out of your pockets i don't trust
you it was the buyer's kid in dc
check the jewelry drawer now it's it i
wasn't like
like once i got caught probably the
seventh or eighth time i was like it's
probably time to
find time to stop your felon over here
well my cuz then they go to my sister
and then they switched then i would
steal coins my dad had this coin
[ __ ] like i don't know it was like a
it's like i think it's like
the thing that he that you they when you
they send you checks okay
and just like they have them all stacked
up and so you remove the checks hide
them somewhere else
and then you just fill up this this box
with quarters and
yeah yeah that became like oh i'm going
to 7-eleven i want to get candy or i
wouldn't then
here and there then i wanted to when i
started smoking at like 13
then it was like you know 225 for a pack
of cigarettes
um and what i was saying was when i got
to ninth grade
uh that was when it like coincided with
with me hearing stone temple pilots core
which is like a very important record to
me i love scott weiland but yeah
and that also got me into wanting to be
into bands more than just like
singing in the mirror and like just
listening to music and dancing around
like a [ __ ]
but i i met this group of kids
that were all kind of like the grunge
you know the smoking section kids
yeah you know what i mean and i started
hanging out with them tasos ben
uh demetrius all those guys and then it
became like all right now we're smoking
pot
now we're doing lsd uh
at 15. uh because i did lsd a few times
up until then but this is pretty garbage
um
when i was 15 years old uh it's probably
the
third or fourth time we i've ever i was
gonna do acid and my buddies were like
let's take
three tabs each it's like 10 of us we'll
set up a 10 in the back of tasos uh
parents house
and we'll just we'll bring a couch in
there candles we'll [ __ ] just do it
up
and it also coincided with the day my
sister had gone away to college that
year
and that was the first night she was
coming back
but i blew it off and i was like well
i'm going to go hang out with my friends
of course i didn't tell them i'm doing
drugs but it's like a big thing for me
to hang out we're going to trip balls
so we each take three tabs we get them
from
there is this you guys you know have
that like dirtbag fam family that lives
in your town so so it wasn't my family
it was the bee crafts so we had the bee
crafts they were they were [ __ ]
trash dude i think one of the sisters
that was in my grade became a prostitute
and the pimp was the brother
god damn family business that ain't big
real garbage
as garbage as you can be did you ever
partake in the uh merchandise no but it
was offered
i was off did you ever kick the tires
over there maybe in like
you don't walk on the lot unless you
want to buy you know what i mean
check it out in ninth grade she was cute
but then i remember seeing her one night
and they were at the wendy's hanging out
smoking cigarettes i think i was off
track we were at the wendy's hanging out
smoking cigs
to pay customers he didn't mention a
burger or nuggets in that whole thing
hanging out we weren't eating no we'd go
in there somebody would buy fries
and we just sit and [ __ ] smoke that's
when you could smoke and they had the
little tinfoil
those used to gross the best or and if
they didn't have that we would take the
comment cards fold that up
and my friend folded it up to an ashtray
no it's real trash if you went over
someone's house and they had like the
little mcdonald's ashtray thing i'm like
you're stealing this what are we doing
it's [ __ ] it's disposable we're using
the big breakfast containers
it's my mick dlt you need the cigarettes
here then put them out over here
so so we we all decide to take lsd
and i we all take it probably around
like eight o'clock and
by about i don't even know man i feel
like this is like three four in the
morning because i this night gets so
crazy
i i go into the tent and i was hanging
on some swings with some friends and i
go into the tent
and tassos is this long-haired greek
dude right and he's sitting on the couch
and he's just like he's like everybody's
like paying attention to him like he's
david koresh
just like this and the meaning of the
world is
is this and time is just nothing and
it's blah and i just i'm
listening and i start freaking out and i
start looking around the tent
and i start seeing swastikas on
everything
just i just i see like swastikas i see
bugs and i'm just like dude i gotta get
out of here
and as soon as i say that everybody
starts following me which starts
freaking me out even more because
they're like what's wrong what's wrong
and i'm just like i gotta go blah blah
and i just take off and i run i it was
probably three miles
from those house to my house i run three
miles like i'm usain bolton yeah
full sprint tracking it full sprint in
that run
i don't remember all of it but dude i
lost touch with reality completely gone
like you hear those stories about that
guy like getting high on lsd and jumping
off like
like a like an apartment because he
thinks he can fly like i was there
where yeah we're going at one point i
remember i was running through the
desert which
which i saw the desert it wasn't like
you know my
my brain whatever it made it be these
kids are getting good [ __ ] down in dc
it's the bee crafts holy [ __ ] it's the b
crafts
yeah quality products this isn't the c
crafts lsb
and crafts and and so i mean
i remember like like flesh is ripping
off my skin i start running through this
field and there's
there's bugs everywhere this giant
praying mantis
eventually i get back to my parents
house and
i start beating on the door because i
don't have my key all i had when
my mom answers the doors i'm holding my
wallet and i'm in my underwear
my mom is like watching a movie my mom's
like what do you
she's like josh what's going on and i
mush her face like move
and i start like running through the
house just all crazy-eyed and i see my
cat and i'm like
who sent you and i throw it and then i
run upstairs and my sister's awake my
dad's awake i'm in their bedroom and i'm
literally like
on the ground like curly from the three
stooges like
and then this is this is the craziest
shutout of all that
is that this is the power of the brain
of what you don't think that you
remember
but at one point i'm on the ground
probably
having a seizure and as i'm looking
around
everybody starts aging backwards my mom
starts getting younger
and younger and younger to the point
where like my first
memories of my mom even the clothes
she's wearing is going
back it's just benjamin button
everything in the room the television
they had a brand new television it goes
back to the older television the bed
sheets
all of it i just kept seeing that's
freaking me out you should have got this
connection
where are the beat crabs at let's get
something to get them on the horn dale
get on that
so so i i remember and so i get to the
he's keeping younger young and younger
and to the point where
then i reenact my own childbirth
i just remember laying on the ground
going ah
it's a baby and i like held my arms up
like i'm [ __ ] kimbers
on goofballs b cats got a good goofball
and then i pass out and then
i wake up the next morning and i'm in my
bed my whole room is trash
and my mom is like crying sitting next
to me just doing that motherly like head
pet
stroking in the hair she's like what
happened last night and i was like
i was like i was at a party and and then
i don't remember anything
yeah she's like someone must have dosed
you yes sir
you know i don't know i remember having
an orange juice and then that's the way
oh we're gonna deny it till the end
you're just as confused as she is we
were at a grateful dead concert and
somebody gave me a sugar cube i was like
sure i love sugar
um wow dude but but it gets better so
she goes she passed away and she goes so
somebody does she goes all right that's
fine she's like you you really scared us
come downstairs we're having breakfast
and then i go downstairs
and we never spoke of it again wow ever
that's an old-school thing never once
there
never weep it under the rug yeah that's
real trash [ __ ] it's like hey when we
we when we get downstairs we get to the
table zipping
we are not emotionally prepared to
process this or speak of this out loud
yeah we will never
speak of it again i got a couple of
those nights too
when i headlined the hollywood improv
[ __ ]
20 years later probably maybe even more
my mom
came she flew from from maryland to to
hollywood to watch me
headline sold it out great super
exciting my mom's sitting of course like
front row
like and she's so excited and in the
middle of my set i just stop and i go
hey mod you remember the time that i
took lsd and then i trashed the house
and reacted my own childbirth
she's like yes i did by the way my mom
sounds just like me what is she smoke
what's her brand
misty120 what the [ __ ] a misty
the [ __ ] skinny the little pinners
well these are very much like capri
yeah 120 is the extra longs
menthol sounds like something from dairy
queen
we got a misty 120 and a dilly bar let
me get a slurpee
a messy 120. cream on the brain and two
crawlers
uh no it was she smoked the long
cigarettes but she was this she was
garbage because she would like light one
take a couple puffs put it down and with
half the like
majority even i'd say like 75 of the
cigarette left she's blazing up another
one
and just saying [ __ ] that so me being
the garbage that i am sure
would go around that night take out
those other butts and [ __ ] puff on
those
yeah man of course smoking old butts out
of the ashtray oh
really it's the best that's dude that's
like when pete jefferson sees somebody
pull like
did they put a sig out then put it back
in the pack oh and i mean i've done that
ah come on dude the rest of the ruins oh
you knocked the cherry off oh
that's fine i don't put any indentations
on it i [ __ ] pop
i smell that it gives the other
cigarettes dude first of all if you're
smoking
you stink i know you know i just started
smoking again
why i don't know because i'm a [ __ ]
jerk-off kid's on the edge
dude flew too close to the sun
now i'll kick i'm gonna kick it i'm
gonna kick out um
but yeah all right let's get into some
[ __ ] questions did you just see that
[ __ ] vape hit that he took too yes
he's got [ __ ] indoors lungs of steel
yeah this is something else all right
we're going to play a little game called
are you garbage
okay we're going to ask you a series of
questions we want you to ask them open
and honestly which i
you're obviously doing uh and if they
spur any stories please feel free to
elaborate we're going to start at the
beginning we're going to answer some of
the standard questions
um now let's go back to when you had the
nice house okay all right well we kept
that no we kept that house that happened
until my dad died in 2010 my mom had
that house
right okay what was the name of the
street that you grew up on
jameson place that's not bad that is
[ __ ] classical the place is good
single single family home okay thank you
you're the only one who knows that
[ __ ] every time we say was it a
single family home they're like
yeah it was just us though it was just
us to live without your [ __ ] pee
break yes i don't think you guys had a
communal [ __ ]
operation going on a failure nobody
knows nobody's ever been on zillow
what's going on
family with the roommates well we were
when we were in the cult nexium
and we had nine families living there no
it was a single family home dude that's
what it was
two uh i know that people's two stories
with the basement
nice unfurnished basement okay we're
showing off
not showing off but which i in i always
remember this
jordan's last game when he won the nba
championship
with the bulls that was the night
because my friend jesse had a single
family home like literally a block away
where we used to go in the basement
smoke pot do drugs that's what his
parents are for his parents didn't give
a [ __ ]
uh but they moved so we needed a
basement and so paul
my my good friend paul oblivin was like
yo man we should he's like do you have a
basement i'm like yeah dude it's on
furniture he goes let's go check it out
we go downstairs
this is when i'm like 18 years old yeah
uh and he sees it he's like oh my god
dude he's like
we could please the potential we could
see that put the television here i'll go
get some carpet for this got an old
couch over there that old couch right
there yeah dude we'll [ __ ] we'll
[ __ ] dust it off i mean there's my
spiders on it oh yeah
we'll put some blankets on it just to
make it feel a little bit more homely
i think steve's got a table at his house
yeah paul
built the table he built the table i got
a couple of two by fours in the truck
i'll be right back
tv on the fridge we put the tv on the
mini fridge
and that downstairs basement became my
drug den
and my sex debt oh yeah of course
because that also coincided with me
being a raver so
so so wednesday thursday friday saturday
so wednesday thursday friday i was at i
was at raves at clubs and on saturday
there were always house parties in dc or
in baltimore
and then on sunday monday tuesday
i would i would meet girls on those
nights at the clubs or the house party
and then sunday monday tuesday i would
go and [ __ ] those girls
all around virginia baltimore [ __ ]
dc i remember i drove to west virginia
once talking about these
talk about the orca man huh guys putting
in work
making house calls
we got we got what do they call
millibites
millipedes thank you millibites
the riffs don't work so we gotta go i
don't even notice
the unfinished basement in the 90s
left unchecked by parents yeah why did
what were they [ __ ]
greatest like people just were like oh i
don't have to look downstairs
it's not what dude all they had to do
was walk three steps down
and everybody's [ __ ] busted cloud of
smoke
cloud what do you think seven 18 year
olds are doing in a basement anyway
you think they're sitting there playing
[ __ ] monopoly we used to we used to
at one point before hoppers are weird
before we shaved eyebrows before we
started with the basement we had my
bedroom and dude i used
a you know decent sized bedroom but not
like much bigger than this
it's too close it's 17 people we'd have
up there we had a pulley system
where we take the [ __ ] screen off the
window we send a bag down this like
like one of those bags you get when you
buy cologne like they go yeah here's
some free swag for some
shoop yeah like a super swag yeah
and and then we'd send the bag down the
rope put the beer in that and we'd bring
it off
wow so then so then we finally have the
basement
was there a separate entrance into the
basement oh yeah dude
one minute one way in one way out still
gage rules hey miss myers hey mr myers
hey
mr myers [ __ ] line all night just
like just wearing a trench coat with
lumps in
it like yeah
or something if that's okay meanwhile
your eyeballs are rolling in the back of
your head
huge pupils just dude i can't tell you
how many times like
i would be down there with a girl
probably inside that girl
and my mom would come down and my dad
would come down to do laundry
yeah and that we'd just have to like
roll over roll over put a blanket over
here or something
all of a sudden you're reading the book
of poetry
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] true yeah we were trash
dude [ __ ] 90s were awesome
god damn it dude i was saying this like
recently it's like man like
you know there's of course these people
are getting busted with saying [ __ ]
that's inappropriate it's like dude we
were raised by the best people oh yeah
it's different
it's a different time man it's like it's
hard it's hard
i'm trying i know you're trying to adapt
but yeah of course nobody gives you
credit to be like well this guy had a
wild childhood you know what i mean yeah
dude
how about uh what's the name of the
grocery store that you went to well
there were two
there was giant giant socks giant food
that's what we're talking about
or safeway safeway's trash
safeway i assume was during the uh
before the 40 years showed up
that was the rental period safeways are
no good are they i i think they are
because better than giant giant food was
i think
like giants got three lane highways
[ __ ] those
can drive an aircraft carrier down those
things
giant giant in our neighborhood giant
was the trash one wow
and safeway was the top of the line it
lives in the upside down
i like it or maybe we're just such
[ __ ] garbage
we think giant's nice but there was one
my brother used to work out shout out
southampton uh
that was nice it was good it must have
been new though maybe it was new
maybe he had an old giant we got our new
our giant was new so
let's see let's see if we can nail this
down i think we could do this all right
at the safeway do you remember
was there the bakery do they have the
bakery inside
good bakery good bakery too head to deli
go get sliced meats
daily deli hit everything dude this
isn't all right so like were they making
sushi in there
not back then not back then sushi was
invented in like [ __ ] 2000
yeah that's a brand new they're doing
kids were they doing sushi and [ __ ]
outside of dc yeah no they're popping
pills
yeah we had one sushi in germantown we
had one sushi place
i forget what it's called it was like
sushi hana or some [ __ ] like that it
was i mean now that i live in los
angeles yeah
sushi it's like tony sushi o'malley's
sushi ball
mozzarella sushi the american cafe
no it was it was but we had one sushi
place and now that i live in los angeles
and i've had
great sushi i'm like i'm that was the
most garbage fish
yeah once you get out of you know we
move from philly
new york and you're like i'm like oh
that's chinese food that's
it's like you have actual authentic good
stuff and i'm like
you're not just like [ __ ] fridays and
apple bees yeah [ __ ] whatever you
know
but we were this is this is something
that might take me off the
the garbage uh level it better be big
well no my dad believed this
uh and this is the the one advice people
always ask me like well you know
if you ever ask somebody like what's the
best advice your dad ever gave you
and my dad's was always go to a
restaurant where you know the owner's
there
because you know you're gonna get better
quality food we didn't we never went to
outback steakhouse
we never went to ruby tuesdays places
like that we
every restaurant we went to was like the
gyms or
just some guy is there owners coming
around the table he's not
on the line how's the alfredo or
whatever like yeah it was it was very
our chinese was like we always went to
the same restaurants mia rancho from
mexican
uh [ __ ] italian pines for italian
it's actually funny
everything had like the name of whatever
the culture was so it's like
chinese chinese china number one yeah
but but we never ate garbage food like
my
my mom was a great chef you know what
she's like she's like a mom chef
you know but it was but it was
phenomenal and the recipes are like
old jewish or like updated [ __ ] like
because she watches cooking network all
day long
um but my dad would never it was always
it was always good
food when we went out to eat that's
pretty good once we always wanted to eat
once a week because we were uh we were
like a big outback applebee we were
we were like trash like yeah like a
birthday was like we're going to
applebee's no we would never do that
we were a combination about we were
local okay not not change my mom just
they wouldn't spend the money on change
but it was always like real shitty
like you know like this place called the
car stop where it was like an applebee's
sounds like a jiffy
but it was local i tell you what the
mozzarella sticks
[ __ ] turn your life around phenomenal
[ __ ] phenomenal how was you you said
your mom was a good cook
oh yeah how was your passover brisket
phenomenal
but dude my mom is my mom is an
incredible
cook like i i don't want to call it cook
i want to call her a chef because
because like it was my like i said my
mom and dad
were like my dad was a good-looking guy
and my mom
just kind of had like started gaining
weight and just you know she drank and
smoked and
and uh she like the only
real time they connected was when they
ate and when they did go i thought it
was a thing but they should not have
been married as long as they were like
it was they were only together because
of us or because like i said my mom
thinks my dad would have probably been
homeless
so the food was kind of what brought us
all together and she would just
all day long when she was on her days
off work was was watch
you know the food network or whatever
getting tips or pbs
whatever was showing like bon appetit or
julia child or whatever the [ __ ]
and she would make those things and and
and nail it
or she'd take a recipe and add her
flavor to it and so
so we'd have friends over to eat and
they would eat my mom's food and then
just be like
holy [ __ ] my mom can't cook for [ __ ]
like miss myers is [ __ ] killing it
my mom's thanksgiving is phenomenal uh
funny thing about my mom and dad though
like it was every year up until he died
was my dad hated brussels sprouts and my
mom
would make brussels sprouts and always
go albert you're gonna have some
brussels sprouts
and he'd be like i'm not eating them so
then the rest of the meal she'd be like
how are the brussels sprouts josh and
i'd be like they're
phenomenal and she like eats super loud
i [ __ ] throw in his face
brussels sprouts is so good they hated
each other they
hated each other but they would go out
to eat and and and like i said man
that's
great though that's great that you at
least have that moment and that
connection of like food
means food was meaningless to me like
growing up it was like not
you guys yeah it was just like huge in
philly
yeah but my mom like my parents were
divorced my mom went back to work it was
like
nobody was home after school and [ __ ] so
it was like then she would she would
work like second or third shift or
whatever so she'd come home late and
it's like
you know yeah i mean i'm not trying to
paint this picture like we were like
[ __ ] destitute or anything nah but
but like it wasn't like you already said
outback yeah you already said you went
down
we did [ __ ] you know she spent a little
case she's gonna bloom and onion she's
not a [ __ ] circle she'll be like camp
you know what i'm in the mood for
tonight kookaburra wings
let's go to outback maybe karabas you
know
i worked out that's trash dude
trash italian fur shorter yeah sunday
dinner at the foleys was [ __ ] on
yeah we never did like i mean we did
walk in as like the sun's going down
from playing you just smell whatever's
[ __ ] cooking
the best it's the best my mom uh for
christmas does the
uh english style so it's like prime rib
uh
vegetables yorkshire pudding like those
and the other thing that we're cause
we're from maryland it's all crab i
don't know you had sickler on here he
probably just like yeah so we pick crabs
dude my mom when every time i go home
now because so my mom
this is you i'll give you [ __ ]
garbage so my dad
she's really like everything you've said
so far
is garbage but everything you're saying
about your mom she might pull you out of
this
get ready god get ready because i don't
know
120 stole a bushel of crap
so so my dad dies in 2010 and my mom
my mom's from norristown oh yeah yeah my
dad's from harrisburg
but they moved down to the dc area in
the 70s and
uh my dad dies in 2010 by this point i'm
already in l.a and my sister
uh moved to i think she by that point
she's living on the eastern shore ocean
city area
of maryland um secrets
island uh mug and mallet so
he just got real tragic so so those are
the things we all drank out of ocean
city dude
i went to senior week until i was 25. oh
my god
i of course you did yeah i mean it was
like it was but
it wasn't it was seniors for everybody
it wasn't just high school that was in
college
it's college too that's what you tell
yourself yeah i'm going for the next
year senior
next year 25 or on a bunch of seniors
you're like a [ __ ] millionaire
oh yeah maybe not 25 okay
i'm a comedian i'm exaggerating for
comedic effect yeah
i still had cut them
so so so my mom uh
sells the house in germantown and moves
up to harrisburg to be by her sister
and her nieces and other cousins they
all everybody else stayed in harrisburg
from my mom's side of the family
my mom had this uh yenta of a [ __ ]
uh her niece but really was almost like
her
her like her like sister like my mom's
sister's daughter okay i was around the
same age as my mom
gotcha and they just all day long drink
coffee
drink wine smoke cigarettes uh sick
cousin said living the life cousin said
she'd just fix her nails all she was
doing was putting on press-on nails all
day long filing her nails
and they were best friends and all they
did was talk
[ __ ] about everybody right but it was
just them
so then my mom's sister sid's mom
roz dies right and my mom my mom's my
mom's a lot i love my mom to death but
she's a lot
uh she i've heard so many conflicting
stories but going by my mom's version
is my mom said all i want out of
roslyn's
is this one lamp that has been in our
family for years right yeah
okay and sid was like okay
and then an appraiser came over and
bought that lamp
and that started the biggest war
between family members like real trash
comes out when someone dies
oh yeah there's a will on the line real
trash comes out baby cause
because sid is saying that my mom was
asking for a bunch of shed and my mom
was just saying she wanted this lamp but
all that trash that they would talk to
one another
sid started telling everybody that my
mom said it so everybody started it's
actually kind of sad everybody started
like dis not disowning
but started taking sid side sid's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i i'll do she almost
stabbed me once with a knife
uh because she was she was going through
a divorce or a breakup whatever the [ __ ]
she was dealing with
and uh and she was making these brownies
called better than sex brownies i was
like a 13 14 year old kid i was smoking
i was cussing
i showed up high yeah and she's making
the brownies she got a bunch of caramel
over there and i grabbed a handful
and she was like don't grab my caramel
and i was like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah and then she just grabbed a knife
and like put it right up to like
my [ __ ] like like not on me but like
yeah like but like aggressively towards
you
yeah and my dad even my dad who like ran
from downstairs and my dad was like what
the [ __ ] sid what are you doing she's
like
and it was just so sid's a [ __ ] whack
job yeah i'd like to retract the class
statement you're
you're absolutely right i told you
jumping like this is garbage
garbage how about a knife being pulled
on you over caramel
yeah or caramel who calls it caramel
that's garbage carmel i like my car
cobbles oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
my mom so then my mom uh sold that house
moved uh to ocean city with my sister
and then to the main point we were
talking about crab every time i go visit
we're right on the [ __ ] ocean
so my mom will buy like two pounds of
jumbo lump crab meat
and just [ __ ] make like i mean
literally like 45
crab cakes and my sister and her husband
they eat some the kids the three my two
nieces and my nephew they
like one each my mom has maybe two and
then i eat like thirty yeah
i could just [ __ ] i feel like it's
not even food like crab like i'm just
like i just eat until i get sick
oh it's sick yeah
[Laughter]
have you ever paid to have anything
airbrushed i don't even know what that
means
you know it's like on the back of a jean
jacket or like uh
like on your car so okay not on my car
or a t-shirt hold on
so i didn't do it okay but
this is what i'm saying you're just
you're asking the right questions
[Laughter]
so um when i was
when i after i graduated high school i
was obsessed with wu-tang clan
me and my friend dead cat his real name
is mike seidenberg well we called him
dead cat
um he's a tax attorney now i think he's
an architect
he did he disowned us twice he got
married found a girl
architecture he found a girl and
disowned us twice
that's um come on dead cat so at that
time you saw ms berg or mike sinberg
we were listening to wu tang and then we
started like
rapping over uh this like this killer
army
uh single and it had like the
instrumentals on it and so he put it on
and i was like oh dude if you take the
headphone
plug it into the mic thing you can rhyme
into one of the headphones
so then we started this all jewish
hip-hop group
called the shackles okay
that's a duh shackles dude
you want garbage i've got the d tattooed
right here
oh my god i've got the s tattooed right
here
oh [ __ ] here dylan watch the show yeah
go ahead wait hold on
there you go get the tricept i've been
working out
brooks lake has has been training me oh
my god
what the [ __ ] the wizards logo
that's trash dude garbage team tattooed
in my body and
all i got a washington redskins [ __ ]
stamp
yo what's great you know how trashy
myers is
is that when he says his friend's name
it's almost like
we know them you know what i mean he's
like we were [ __ ] joey
you know jimmy frog legs right you know
jimmy so so we did
so with the shekels the music got better
the first album
i'm not buying it but sure i like their
later [ __ ]
dude we dude all right so the sheckles
first album's gazook's
second is flight of fear third was
buddha tributa
fourth was sassagrass then we have did
you sign with rca how many [ __ ]
albums
in in about six months dude they were a
[ __ ] hitman
turning those [ __ ] out dude
phil spector producing
but then oh dude once we got past
sassagrass
then we started getting experimental
with sergeant buddha's smokey bone club
band
that was and then we had just descend to
sheckle six
we just caught it it was just
self-titled
and then we had the greatest hits to
sheckles banks these guys had the balls
to put out our greatest hits
it was just a cassette just because
every album was like 42 songs would you
move any of these
any units no but we we would like put
them on at parties
and the party would end pretty much
because this is also around the time
like no limit soldiers and [ __ ] like
mysticals that is at his highest
big mystical guy shout out to no limit
what did you do um that was just [ __ ]
wild dude so all right so the sheckles
became so happy
talks about it like it's the [ __ ]
beetles the sheckles did not become
underground
[Laughter]
it's super we're cool
in my basement where are they available
so my friend
uh mike barbaresi who who also
who also was like also an architect
awesome he wasn't barbarisi ain't jewish
no he's not no no but he he he guessed
it on a couple records hey
you gotta have features i mean it's not
an album if you don't have features i
was the only jew
i was the only jew i always say all
jewish because we called it the sheckles
but i think like
paul was episcopalian and then i think
uh dead cat
was maybe like christian catholic one of
those things well you had to get into
the business somehow yeah
yeah you got me i'm the jew i'm the i'm
the head i'm the rhythm you do the
talking in the in the pitch meetings
oh dude so so mike barbarisi
came home he's like dude i just went to
ocean city i got a surprise for you and
he got the sheckles
airbrushed on a tv on a t-shirt yeah i
never did it
i never did you ever wear that shirt god
damn right you're [ __ ] driving
you my
made me think of something when you said
you showed up at your parents house and
you didn't have keys
did either one of you guys ever have the
[ __ ] little key the little key rock
that you would hide
the back window you could get i mean you
could get into it you could spot that
thing from down the street you're like
that's not a rock
it's not a real rock yeah it's [ __ ]
garbage
we didn't i'm trying to remember like
where we had we had our like separate
key
i maybe maybe the next door neighborhood
yeah that was big back in the day yeah
yeah yeah i gave it to the next door
neighbor that was why i beat on the door
at six in the morning and woke my mom
because i was like wow we didn't put the
rock out
we didn't put the rock out i thought
like it was first i thought this was
somebody had it a friend of somebody i
thought it was reserved for like [ __ ]
spies was the magnet like under the car
i was just gonna say that you remember
that oh dude you could pull like a
magnet box put a key in the box and the
magnet you would put it under your car
like in the driveway or whatever so you
can always get into the house my friend
craig who's a comic craig conan
in la uh he we did a show at the magic
castle we're doing like drive-in style
shows
so we park our cars on this one level
and you know because we haven't seen
each other in so long we're hanging out
until like two in the morning after the
show ended at 10.
and craig locked his keys in the car and
he goes he goes don't worry man he lives
under his car pops up the rock recently
he's got the right two weeks ago
two weeks ago then he pulled out a big
math billy bastard
dude you guys want to book him i got you
he's definitely garbage
holy [ __ ] wow i only yeah i only
remember seeing that back in like the
90s someone having the [ __ ] hidden
key the hidey key now
holy you guys got a hundred thousand
instagram followers he's got a [ __ ]
key
magnetized to his car that's [ __ ]
awesome
you got one i got one have you ever been
a part of or been to a bikini car wash
you look like you orchestrated a couple
of the others yeah i know down there at
secrets
so i could give you the most garbage of
all garbage lay it on us
i was a strip club dj for six years holy
[ __ ]
jesus did you ever get involved in these
strippers come on dude that's awesome
but but always dip your company
especially if you're a [ __ ] strip
club but
i listen i can count on my hands how
many strippers in the six years that i
hooked up with because
the first club i remember strip club he
never said that it's called dingles
it's called the manhole so so my first
strip club sorry so i i moved to la and
i for the wait you did this in l.a
in los angeles yeah oh but no no no no
full listen listen so check it out so i
i couldn't find a job when i started
stand-up so when i moved to la
i worked in television like doing pa
work i was i was a pa for keeping up
with the kardashians for two seasons wow
okay
the first two seasons i used to in a
sense
babysit kendall and kylie because i was
such a bad pa they'd be like just go
play with kendall and kylie keep him out
of the shoot
go play video games with him whatever um
and then i worked on a reality porno
called foursome on playboy tv uh i
hooked up a couple girls on that
that was an o-r or f-o-u-r-s-m
so we but then i i started stand up
and i couldn't find work that would work
with my schedule schedule sure
and i was never a good server i i got
fired from every restaurant job i ever
had
so there was a there was a comic at the
comedy store
named alex uh moore and he was a
bouncer at spearmint rhino and he goes
he goes dude
because i was a wedding dj for seven
years that's how i that's how i got
weddings was yeah trash it's trash but i
was good
you're always like i'm not saying you
aren't good but it's always like the guy
pulling the speakers out of his he got
real defensive about that i love him
i was the king of ultrasound dj's good
ones are good ones are great dude if you
have a good one
they make or break the [ __ ] for sure
everything but i think it was more
like maybe my more where my personality
uh you know wasn't as you know because
dude i was drinking and
yeah [ __ ] you know i'd be hungover
doing coke all night and then show up to
the [ __ ] goldberg wedding
like oh [ __ ] we're cutting this one
short tonight
one time i did coke with the bride and
groom at a seven hour wedding in like in
like
real rural maryland um but
i moved to l.a what if they're still
together i think if you're doing below i
wish i could find out
probably i would say probably not no
but they're they're they're so similar
at that point it's not like the ones
doing it behind the back
startup unless one got a dui had to
clean up their life
yeah and then the bride's like listen
i'm [ __ ] i'm riding if one of them
got sober yeah
i might do it um kill you but so i so
when alex knew that i used to be a
wedding dj he goes dude he's like i know
you're looking for work i'm telling you
right now
if you go to a strip club just go to
like pick out five strip clubs tomorrow
and go apply and i bet you get hired at
two of them
and he was right i got hired the first
one i went to and
uh i remember there was their dj like
their names
this is well this is out this is they're
all the good ones are all out in the
valley like north hollywood
pacoima um or downtown la which is the
last one i worked out which was like an
atm i made so much [ __ ] money
i don't make money what do they tip you
out or what so i so i'll tell you this
and then i'll tell you how you make the
money
so this the dj at the first club i got
hired out was a club called desire
and i mean this place was [ __ ] even
though he said rash
desire it was trash
guys thanks for coming out to the lunch
shift at design
give us just a taste of bringing
somebody sorry be like oh
yeah y'all that's what i'm talking about
right there give it up for
paprika guys all right guys buy two
dances get one free
this is the best save a little bit of
green get everything
in between you know what i'm saying
y'all come on i'm chubbing up
dawg hey we got any ones in there
somebody call my wife i'm on my way
so the first club i get hired at
they have this real this like huge
samoan guy is the dj
no [ __ ] his name is murder murder
huge simone like literally boogie down
productions or
booyah tribe whatever that [ __ ]
hip-hop group of samoans is
he wears glasses and a [ __ ] huge suit
and he's like he's like you have a dj
before and i was like well i did
weddings and he goes now i'm talking
about the strip club and i'm like no he
goes
there's only one rule get that
money girl wants to hear a song
cool five dollars cause you need to get
that money everything you could charge
girls for
everything why does she sound like uncle
ben
[Laughter]
get that money so he taught me very
early on he goes
he's like if you're gonna [ __ ] these
girls man you're gonna [ __ ] up your
money
so he goes dude look at he's like you
can make money
if you just stay focused literally when
you get to that strip club
just like the girls the girls that make
money are the ones that are like money
money money money money not the ones
that are like
oh i want to like get you know i want to
talk [ __ ] with this girl i want to get
high with this girl
yeah yeah it's if you go into a strip
club focus to make money you can [ __ ]
clean up
so i worked out you would charge the
strippers dude i had
so many hustles especially i so i'll
just use dames and games which was the
last one i worked at
because it was a it was a topless bar
now why is everything rhyme in a strip
club
dame's a game names and games green in
between la's a [ __ ] weird town man
la la land baby well the the save a
little bit of green get everything in
between that was like my thing that was
that was like everybody has like weird
things like more breasts and thighs than
popeyes like
all right
if y'all go to [ __ ] scores i bet the
dj's like all right
welcome to scores well you won't be born
get some more at scores coming up next
cilantro guys
it's always spices this stripper named
cilantro give it up for cystic fiber
[Laughter]
so but i but i learned very very quickly
how much money
can be made at these clubs because i
always work day shifts so i could do
comedy at night yeah
and when i got to dames and games
because i worked i worked day shifted
at well i worked desire i only worked
there for two weeks then i got fired
because i went out of town even though i
covered my shifts they just like removed
me yeah
from the schedule which was a blessing
because then i then when i got back from
from being home visiting i went and
applied to the spearmint rhino and got
hired at rouge
and when i started at rouge day shifts i
was making like you know like a hundred
dollars a shift day shift it was
good i worked a couple days a week then
i became monday through friday
every you know every day work from like
11 a.m to 7 p.m go hit spots after
that's perfect
it was cool and i was dating a girl um
who
who didn't care but also i wasn't like i
never i've never cheated
yeah i never i've never while i was with
a girl i've never cheated
um but then
uh a whole bunch of different [ __ ]
happened to me i got in this bad car
accident when my friend passed away
um another comic and i
i then i was like on drugs like hardcore
opiates for like
seven eight months then i got sober and
went back to the strip club
um and i worked there for a couple
months and then
i saw they were building this club in
downtown l.a called names and games so i
called up corporate or i wrote him an
email and i was like yo man
i worked at rouge in the valley for
[ __ ] three years
i really i live closer to downtown can i
please get hired as a dj or it can be
considered
and immediately when that place was
opening they brought me in for an
interview and i became the daytime dj
and i was making like
250 300 just day shift it was packed
dude
every day cash and and and then
green is mean and then you're no djing
that wasn't bad riffing here i mean it's
a little nasally they don't want to hear
like all right
surprise your wieners uh yeah so
um so i was working there for maybe like
four or five months and they were upset
with their nighttime dj who worked
literally he worked tuesday through
saturday and
it was like a fun place it wasn't the
typical strip club like workers like
the gm was this guy steve who came from
nightclubs and bars but he was just a
cool guy that i was like really becoming
cool with
and he goes listen josh he goes um we're
really upset with jacob so
would you like to start working nights
i'm like nah man i got comedy he goes
dude
just work one night just work one yeah
and then tell me if you don't want the
money or not
and i worked one night and i made 500
bucks and i was like and i did nothing
same [ __ ] i did day shift and i was like
all right so i can work
two night shifts to make up for the five
six you know
day shifts i was working so i started
working thursday and friday nights
and it was just instantaneous to learn
how to make money so let's say the
popular song at the time was [ __ ]
love me by lil wayne right every girl
wants to dance to that but you can't let
every girl dance
because you can't play it yeah you can't
but they get annoyed so i'd be like if a
girl comes up she's like i want [ __ ]
love me i'll go right that's 100 bucks
it's your song all night give me under
box right now boom
then a girl would be like hey i got a
guy here that's about to throw money on
me
i know i just went up four girls ago
couldn't you throw me back up and i'd be
like i'd be like honey man
there's 50 girls working tonight that
all want to go on stage
all right here's what i'll do i'll put
you up next but i need half that money
so you need to bring the money over to
me i'll count it and then i'll give you
your half and i'll keep my half
all right done all right then there was
disguise coming up hey man can i get uh
you know can you get my girl next and
i'm like all right you gotta it's a
hundred bucks just to me perfect booze
or 20 bucks whatever whatever it was
whatever it was it was money money money
money and then it was just
um you know also just being funny
yeah and just being having a good
personality well if you're a comedian
if being a comedian can take you a long
way in a lot of a lot of situations you
know what i mean like if you're like
emceeing something or dj it's like yeah
you have the natural knack to [ __ ] go
very much yeah yeah yeah and and but it
also was a job that destroyed me
uh because
as i was working at damson games i got
new faces just for laughs thinking
thinking
i was going to quit the job yeah you're
gonna be famous and i'm gonna be famous
yeah
um that didn't happen yeah so i had to
go back to work and that caused and then
i and also like i had gotten sober-ish
uh but then i i started like because to
get to that club in downtown l.a you
gotta you gotta drive through downtown
by pill alley which is where i used to
buy dope and there's the pill alley is
like fifth and broadway in in downtown
l.a
and there's just like a shitload of guys
selling oxies
selling fentanyl whatever so i just i
hated the job
because i gotta go to this place that
[ __ ] yeah like andrew santino doesn't
have to work at a strip club
and i do sam morrell we all did new
faces together but i'm the one that saw
the [ __ ] day job yeah yeah and that
killed me yeah
so i started getting high and and then
i created the goddamn comedy jam which
started really blowing up
and then it was like when can i quit
this place
when can i find steve's gone at this
point there's this manager mitch that's
like a trump supporter even pre-trump he
was just
like i remember when trump was like was
like because i quit there
january of 2016 and which was
actually they fired me but it was a
blessing um
because then i i sold the tv show and we
made that that following
june but i remember him being like he
was the first person that i
that i knew that said yeah i kind of
like what trump's saying and i was like
what the [ __ ]
i was like you're trash dude that guy's
a [ __ ] racist
yeah i know and i'm [ __ ] feeling it
but um as the jam was taking off
i remember one week so cool the jam
yeah you're a cool guy we did so we did
we sold out
uh great cool guys we sold thank you
very much you're a cool guy too
i'm a cool guy we sold out about it for
new york
good job [ __ ] johnny on the spot
they're killing it one good drop out of
40.
it's on the board so we we had done the
new york comedy festival
in 2015 and
the jam was at gramercy we we were the
hottest show there
yeah i mean i remember it was burns this
wasn't that long ago no
burr uh hannibal eliza big jay mateo
i mean the tickets were we sold out and
like and we took all the chairs out it
was just like we got to make it a rock
concert
sold that out um and i remember the next
day after that
like literally that we did that on
november 13th at midnight we were still
doing the show it was my birthday
november 14th
and i remember you know seven eight
hundred people singing me happy birthday
also i was high as [ __ ] on oxy 30s
super 30s just scratching myself nose
running so much for this so brian
dude i have i went to high school the
kids are like yeah dude i'm doing perk
80s i'm like nah dude they're oxies
you're not doing a perk 120 okay the
park just it just sounds good yeah i
mean
it sounds like a little more fun you
know what i mean it kind of reminds me
of friends they used to say
central park so we so i remember we did
that and then the next day
burr rented uh some drums and some amps
so my band uh right before he headlined
medicine i remember that yeah
jammed in madison square garden as
they're setting everything up it was one
of the coolest moments of my life
um and then a week later i'm at the
exact same [ __ ] moment
i'm being yelled at by a stripper in
downtown la because i still had to work
there i didn't
wasn't making enough money and because
of that that like
i could not compartmentalize that strip
club djing is the job
that supports the career and because you
don't
realize how long it [ __ ] takes dude
it took
eight years from the time i moved to la
and started stand up to be able to quit
my job
and support myself as a comedian god i
really want to keep smacking this thing
you guys haven't done that at all
professionals over here but so i it was
it was like it just
it made me depressed it made me sure
it's tough man
i mean yeah we're going through it i've
gone through it it's [ __ ] yeah you
know
but it's like here's the cool thing
about being the strip club dj is that i
i
quit and i remember i always you say the
happiest moment i'll ever be is when i
quit the strip club
and they removed me from my shifts
because i
started calling out um because they let
me work on like
thanksgiving and then i had to work on
christmas because i got a bell on
thursday off shift thanksgiving at a
[ __ ] stream well i worked that
thanksgiving
so november 15th stuffing november of
2015.
double actually the kitchen at dave's
games wasn't bad
i [ __ ] knew he was gonna say yeah
it's a trash date it's a trash like the
caesar salad but with like thigh meat
you're like a chicken breast is that
like a pun
is that like a whole is that like a bit
no deserve you the
you're getting caesar's salad and it
ain't chicken breasts
you're [ __ ] up dude the guy remember
the chef goes nah thigh meat's more
tender and juicy
i'm like oh come on dude chicken breasts
is this a joint
what is this
save the ligaments for me but i
i remember we so that thanksgiving had
to work and then christmas was coming up
and i was also
going to like i wasn't buying dope from
downtown i had a pain doctor
in beverly hills dr k he's the shadiest
guy in the world i'll give a [ __ ] i'll
call him out
because he's killing people yeah like
really killing people like
uh because he would just you should be
like he'd be like what do you want and
i'd be like
uh i don't know as many perk 30s as you
can give me all right well your
insurance will let me give you 90 for
free so here you go
500 for the appointment and i mean he'll
be like when you want to get off just
let me know i'll put you on subscribe
so um i remember i re-up with him
we did the jam that december with
uh with sarah silverman and louie
dropped in it was like really it was
dope this is all pre louis getting
canceled or whatever uh and then i
i remember i saw star wars the the first
the force awakens i was [ __ ] up at
like three in the morning just
scratching myself high on drugs
and then that thursday i called out or
that friday i called out
then a week later was christmas and i
called out that time but i got the
shifts covered but they took me off
the the calendar from that point on they
wanted me to work uh sundays and mondays
which are no money days
and i was pissed but i go well i gotta
have vocal cord surgery in february so
i'm just gonna quit anyway because we i
already sold the show to comedy central
we're gonna make it and cut to
june of 2016 uh we just the day after we
shot the hour special for the goddamn
comedy jam
my agents got me tickets to go see the
dodgers play the nationals at dodger
stadium and i remember i was driving
on sunset boulevard with my buddy avery
and it just so happened to be the exact
road that i took to get to the strip
club
and i just started like weeping because
i was like as long as i don't [ __ ] this
up yeah i'll never have to go back there
as like in a professional way right yeah
go for pleasure
oh no and i have yeah i did i've gone
back there and i've gotten lap dances
and but also it's more if i go there now
i just picture the strippers like so
how's the comedy thing yeah
they don't even realize how good i've
been doing like they have
no [ __ ] idea they don't their world
is their way of course
are you still trying to do comedy and
i'm like yeah i've sold
two tv shows
i'm doing all right but uh i go back
sometime like once a year and it's more
just to remind myself
like don't do drugs just stay the course
because you don't want to come back here
oh
yeah i kill myself i kill myself i know
it's fine you know it's it's [ __ ]
scary
well look it came out the other end damn
all right this is
this is going to be called hollywood
trash for sure
that's a [ __ ] name right there let's
do uh let's let's run through a couple
quick ones just like yesterday
yeah yeah i'm sorry i got i got caught
out so much fun that's what happens when
we have good guests that we like hanging
we don't get to that many questions
that was a [ __ ] brilliant story yeah
that was [ __ ]
it's also sometimes like happy endings
in this [ __ ] too right of course i'm
referring i told you i'm referring
to positivity now baby i'm positive i
read camus
like i'm [ __ ] i got come on dude
let's do some of the uh some of the
basics right
okay uh growing up did you drink milk
with dinner never
okay my man do you brush your teeth in
the shower
never my [ __ ] dude this guy might
[ __ ] put his
cap on he might be coming baby
no whammies no emmys um all right what
do you got
uh brush your teeth in the shower
um growing up what did you leave the
butter was it in the refrigerator or on
the
fridge okay all right this guy's [ __ ]
this guy's [ __ ]
shut up i told you my family wasn't
trash i'm trash
okay wait the milk was no they're all
nose
toothbrush was known the butter was now
but i got i got
i got uh from an expert an expert wrote
in to a she's a he's a
he's like a he's a chef in australia and
he cleared it up for me
the salted so salted butter you're
allowed to leave out for spreading
because it's salted it's preserved it
doesn't need to be cold
unsalted needs to be unsalted as cooking
and needs to be kept out or
it can be kept in because you're just
cooking with it it doesn't matter how
incredible should there be an amendment
to this question too
is it butter or margarine margarine's
trash potato and margarine it's just
your margin growing up never we were
never we
might i remember seeing country crock in
the fridge like once well i think people
tried it they're like what's this let's
try it i have it now it's all chemical
what is it
it's just chemicals i don't know i go
back to my mom's and it's like literally
biting into a battery i'm like what the
[ __ ] are we doing
all right this is the this is the
trifecta on this one
um after you open the ketchup where does
it belong in the refrigerator and the
cabinet
refrigerator and what about the maple
syrup
cabinet wow this guy's clean i don't
know what happened
think i mean we was a strip club he just
flipped it on us
i feel like you want to be garbage but i
got news for you man
he's trash i i'm trash i am 100
trash pure trash he just put a little
[ __ ] polish on the end of it i told
you dude it's like we
the family my family was like if i ever
said we were lower middle class when we
were then my parents were like no we're
not we're middle class like
my dad was refined my dad exposed me to
the arts like i have a miles davis
tattoo because my dad used to play
jazz records with me and take me to like
[ __ ] see rebel without a cause
i mean like i grew up yeah you're
freaking you said you're from good stuff
you just made all you're just trash i'm
sure the trash my sister's a [ __ ]
doctor her husband's the
the assistant d.a to maryland whatever
sakamo
whatever native american is jewish rap
group tattoo
all right he's [ __ ] trash he's got
airbrushed t-shirts come on what are we
doing
what was the name of the place perk
alley what'd you call a pill alley
fear the broadway holy fully's gonna
need the address for me before we get
out of here by the way dylan get me to
laguardia quick
wait where is your where is your where
is your drug alley here
we're not telling you i don't want your
phone i'm not working on it no no i
don't want your blood on my hands myers
i'll tell you where our drug alley is
you're sitting across from me
i'm rattling around like a [ __ ]
rattlesnake
josh hano myers ladies and gentlemen
thank you josh what do you want the
folks out there tonight
nothing to promote
listen to my podcast uh the 500 with
josh out of myers i'm going through
rolling stone magazine's list of the 500
greatest albums
actually today it was a bombshell
rolling stone magazine
updated their 500 greatest album list
we've been going off the 2012 one
we're two years in uh and it's like it's
changed everything like i don't know
i gotta record something now because i
already recorded the intro for the
episode that comes out tomorrow
it's a whole thing dude
it's good if anything it just if
anything it just extended the podcast
let's go yeah
so more money it's a blessing in
disguise listen to the podcast
uh support it in whatever way you can uh
but mostly just listen that's all i care
about
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes as always full video available on
youtube
you can subscribe there gas digital
network use promo code ayg you get to
join the chat you get the [ __ ]
you get like the last 10 years of
[ __ ] legion of skanks that's worth
the [ __ ] work seven bucks a month or
whatever it is
touring should be worth more than that
use promo code ayg uh we get to wet our
beaks a little bit we appreciate it
thanks so much everybody came out to the
live show in philly which is going to be
happening
uh yeah guys appreciate the support yes
we appreciate you guys we love you shout
out to everybody in the live chat that
uh that goes back and forth with us we
love all you guys and we appreciate you
guys
and we will see you next week peace